and thank you for having me you know
it's been a couple of years that i've
been trying to make it to stanford
and i haven't been able to travel for a
variety of reasons easily and here we
are with
pandemic making a virtual visit possible
so i'm really excited to be here and i'm
hoping the network will be more reliable
for the rest of the hour i haven't had
these kinds of troubles before but
of course they've picked their time
um so let me pull up my slides
so um thank you i did hear you mention
the newly founded create center
and i actually want to highlight one
other center which is dfab the digital
fabrication center at uw which i'm also
part of although not directing
um and a lot of what i'm going to talk
today about is actually featuring things
that happened
through dfab because i'm
i decided to focus today's talk or guide
it
based on the work that i spent the
spring doing in reaction to the arrival
of cobit 19. so what you see on this
slide
is actually a picture of a whole pile
of face shields that i spent one night
many of us assembled but i in particular
this pile was one that i spent a long
night assembling so that we could
deliver them to the local hospital
um and the team that i was part of
actually um was a very large team i'll
introduce it in a second
but these this is the set of things that
we worked on over the spring
face shields isolation gowns um clips
that would hold tubes together
eye production um head and shoe covers
surgical masks non-rebreather masks
vacuum face tents n95s peppers
and ca pr repairs so it was a really
wide ranging effort
and i'm just going to focus on a few of
these but just to give you a sense
also of the team it involved
physicians um someone from the va who
led um actually ended up winning an
award for her work in doing
safety testing on this front a whole
pile of engineers both from uw and
beyond if you see scott hudson in there
and various other people as well and and
many
students and faculty who are not
pictured on that slide were part of this
effort
and what we did um was um
timelines coming in a second but right
at the start of the pandemic
this team came together and um the face
shields that you see here were actually
designed by tim prestero who's part of
design.thatmatters.org but then they
were
modified from peru's design specifically
to add the
visor that helped stop drops from coming
into the face
and this is probably the most well-known
design
that was 3d printed worldwide many
varieties of this
kind of design were printed by designers
all over the place
the version that tim worked on was
actually submitted to the fda or
actually the nh3d print exchange
on 331 and was clinic reached clinical
approval
meaning it was safe to use in hospitals
within about two weeks of that date and
um the uw side of this was primarily
documentation
quality assurance and production and we
delivered about a thousand of these in
seattle
um and by the way if you haven't heard
about how these were made
one of the fun things about it was that
we went all over campus collecting
transparencies of the type that i
used to give talks with in the 90s when
i was a grad student which had been
sitting in drawers
all over campus for a really long time
and that's what makes up the shield part
of these
um along with the three-hole punch they
are prepared to to clip onto the face
shield
um another thing that we went pretty far
with was these kinds of gowns
um this was submitted to nih in late
april but it's still not approved and
that's one of the many things i'm going
to hopefully talk about a little bit
today
despite the fact that garbage bags are
still being used in some places
where gowns are in short supply and i'm
going to
hope that somebody will tell me if
there's an interruption please do feel
free to tell me if there are questions
um i'm having trouble seeing both your
faces and my slides so
i'm feeling a little cut off but that's
okay
um we'll unmute ourselves if there's a
question
excellent um so another area
that i was pretty closely involved in
and that we did a lot of work in had to
do with
masks and masks is a really diverse
thing
the thing that we worked the hardest on
was actually what you might call fit to
face
because for many mask applications it's
really important
that air not escape around the edges of
the mask so it has to fit your face
really well
and given a mask that has good fit to
face you can attach all sorts of things
to it you can attack
attach different kinds of filters you
can use it as a non-rebreather
there's lots of things you can do with
it and so that kind of this tree just
shows some of the things that we played
around with in the mask space
and we did get clinical approval for a
surgical mask which is
less protective than an n95 mask
it's the kind of thing that people wear
around when they have paper masks on
those are surgical masks the m95s
are sometimes also you see them on
consumer spaces
um but they are have a tighter fit to
face and a different filter material
um and we also got to the point where we
were doing testing in the field
for an an n95 replacement and a
large-scale scale
large scale meaning produced at scale
non-rebreather
um i just wanted to highlight this one
last one because
although it wasn't a focus of the work i
was part of
it's one of the few that has a label
built into it and we'll talk a little
bit later about why labeling is so
important um and so what you can see
here is that um
actually when this is 3d printed it's
just got a hole
where the label is and that label is
important because what
the two tubes that you attach with this
particular clip are specified by the
label and different tubes
have different diameters and different
clips are needed um
in terms of timeline this all started
march 21st
with a an email by
monday we were approved to go on campus
and we collected 3d printers from all
over uw's campus and put them in the
mechanical engineering building
and within about a week we had a team
running
the printers 24 7 to produce face masks
um and a bunch of other things going on
as well within two weeks we had the
clinical approval of the face shields i
shouldn't say fda approval because those
are different um
in april we started on the gown designs
and submitted those in late april
um by may we had delivered all of the
masks that we were
going to deliver we were approved to
also supply them to some of the
on-campus
workers who were um still being exposed
regularly
as well as uw hospitals but we're never
approved to
deploy them more broadly than that and
i'll talk about that too a little bit
um we did a lot of documentation work
hoping that others would be able to
produce those things and we have that up
on the dfab website
and then we began to close things down
in june
okay although i'm focusing on our work
with covid i do want to say that this
talk is informed by a series of
ethnographic and interview studies that
have been done
since 2016 primarily with megan hoffman
and scott hudson and megan as my phd
student he'll be graduating in just over
a year
hint and has been very
strongly involved in a bunch of this
work um
so it started with a sort of process of
us designing things for upper limb
prosthetic users where we were the
designers and 3d printers and everything
else we did similar work with clinicians
in their clinics
in 2016 um sorry in 2019 with
occupational therapists and in between
we did
interviews and other things with e-nable
volunteers and the
mabel is this national actually
international organization of people who
are 3d printing
not exactly prosthetic hands for kids
and there's a lot of questions about how
well that goes
and actually just this year we submitted
a chi paper safe savage and i where we
talk to
people all over the world who were
printing enable hands because
there's a lot of things that are like
really cool looking superhero themed get
into the media
and then nobody really knows what
happens after that but it doesn't seem
like they're lasting very long as
success cases
and assistive technology of course has a
very high advantagement rate and there
are
potentially negative consequences there
interestingly in latin american
organizations that we interviewed where
the barriers between clinical work and
maker work are seem to be lower and the
collaborations seem to be stronger we
see
a very different outcome and some of
that
kind of barrier lowering really happened
in the covid case as well
so anyway in addition we've done
interviews with a bunch of people who
are
embedded in the medical system in the us
who make um and
and just this whole suite of things with
different stakeholders taken together i
think is
a really informative way to approach how
do we do this and how do we do it right
so the rest of this talk is going to
focus on challenges that came
out of and are illustrated by our
coveted work but are also informed by
that body of work that i just showed you
and the first challenge that i want to
talk about is
quality assurance or quality control and
what you're seeing here
is images from the documentation page
that um
aiden fay who is a stanford alum you may
remember him from his time there
helped put together and
he helped us um try to show people
how to tell what was um
properly 3d printed in the face um
shield
domain so this is where the transparency
would be attached
because we were having a huge error rate
not a majority but probably between a
third and a half of the things that
people
would deliver needed to be thrown out
because it has to be printed at high
quality to be safe
and we actually developed based um in
part on work that megan did with an
organization in colorado called make for
coven we developed a qa sheet and i'm
showing an excerpt from permit in black
here at the top
that has to be attached to every bag
that's delivered to the hospital
with these things checked off that bend
tests smoothing
labeling cleaning um and so on we're
done
um so that they can be confident that
what they're giving the workers who are
going
into these unsafe situations is properly
produced
um and in all of the hospitals that we
worked with on the uw end
safety really came before quantity or
even access to
uh ppe personal protective gear
and so they would rather reuse things
that they knew were safe
even if that was not ideal than have us
deliver things they could not count on
um interestingly
make for kobe the organization that
megan worked with in colorado delivered
about 80
000 of these face masks and other ppe
in comparison to the thousand that we
successfully delivered in seattle
just want to take a moment to think
about the magnitude of difference there
make for kobed was almost entirely
makers and other volunteers and they
were such a large organization that they
actually had pilots
bringing things to parts of colorado
that they couldn't drive too quickly
um they the group involved academics
um as well as makers in general and they
ended up collaborating really
effectively
they generated a ton of documentation
and
they were um able to produce at a scale
that we never reached at uw
um both had problems with quality
assurance
but make for covet had a different
structure for how the volunteers could
collaborate and a different level of
trust we never achieved that level of
trust with the makers
in the seattle area that the academics
and others who were
hosting make for covet achieved in
colorado
um and we have a in submission paper
talking about some of those differences
going back to quality assurance for a
second just showing here sort of the
the way in which um so this bucket here
is full
of wipes that needed to be used
obviously
masks and gloves and here are some of
the garbage bags with the qa
sheets attached that we then delivered
to the uw hospitals
um i want to focus on labeling for a
second this was actually not a problem
we solved
it turns out that because there are so
many varieties being produced and
in at least the seattle area there were
people producing faith shields who
weren't necessarily certified as in part
of the uw system and known to be
using proper methods hospitals needed a
way to keep track of where things came
from so they could reject stuff that
wasn't trustworthy
and it ended up being these garbage bags
that were that process
for uw area hospitals that we worked
with
because there was no good way to label
these face shields especially
once they were cleaned if they were they
were meant to be used
reused and the wipes that were cleaning
them could actually wipe away even
permanent ink
um anything that we did that was
embedded or cut out
potentially would be hard to clean
properly because it created little bumps
and negative spaces that
were harder to wipe down so that was not
a problem we solved easily
um and these kinds of variations like
this one at the top that doesn't have
the
visor were not considered acceptable at
least by the uw hospital because of the
risk of
droplets coming over the top so there
were just a lot of
variations floating around that needed
to be controlled
um i also want to mention um and this is
coming from
our prior work so this is a workshop we
did in 2016 with
enable folks and clinicians that one of
the things that we saw
being problematic was what you might
call a conflict between community
values and clinical values and this is
something that was overcome much more
easily
for whatever reason in colorado than in
seattle would make
for making for covid but in
enable cases for example it hasn't
really been overcome in the us but in
latin american sites that we studied it
had been
um so the difference here of help where
you can versus do
no harm is surprisingly strong so for a
maker
help where you can is kind of a core
value that we found in many of the
interviews we've done
for a medical professional they
literally swear an
oath when they graduate to do no harm
and um
it turns out that this can actually
create deep-rooted conflicts we actually
had a team member
who was threatened when she raised the
question of safety and quality
assurance in a social network setting
where makers were gathering
not from colorado but in another site
there was somebody threatened to ship
her covet infected
masks that she should put on her face
just because she brought up quality
assurance
so um people felt really threatened
by the idea that their wish to help
would be reined in
it seems and the trust between
clinicians and makers was not always
strong
um and these kinds of rifts affected the
quantity of things that could be
produced and the quality of things that
were being produced and i think are very
concerning
um it's really hard to unpack them
there are structural issues there are
cultural issues there's a lot of
different things going on that can lead
to an outcome like this
um another difference between clinical
work and make
maker work is the focus on longitudinal
support and whole case management
um a lot of the groups that we have
interviewed over the years who are not
on the clinical side
don't see their responsibility as
necessarily extending beyond the
delivery of something or that the making
of something cool
and to successfully produce technology
that is solving
medical problems it's especially
assistive technologies but i would say
even ppe
right there needs to be some sense of
longitudinal follow-up
um we don't have as much data on that in
the ppe space because
things have been happening so quickly
with covid but certainly in the
assistive technology space abandonment's
really high
and again there are these risks if
somebody abandons
they then won't go back and use
technology that they need that they
might be able to get from a more
reliable source
um and it just increases the
chance that something will not be used
um so
this is a space that needs attention um
okay that's enough for challenge one
number one challenge number two is the
design
process how do you collaborate across a
distance um we had
teams located in homes and labs in
pittsburgh in california in washington
seattle and then testing that had to be
done in hospitals which we did in
seattle
that were being done in clinics that
were being done in some cases by the nih
in a different part of the country
um and all of these groups had to
collaborate effectively and we had to
collaborate on
issues like whether or not something fit
a face that really required
some level of in-person understanding um
so this was a really challenging aspect
of what we did and particularly with
covert where there are people who
literally even in the same city couldn't
enter the same space with each other and
feel comfortable
it came up quite significantly um
the another challenge for the design
process was
was the fit to face challenge it wasn't
just challenging because of distance it
was
a very challenging thing to accomplish
period
um the everyday tools that we
were using just simply didn't model the
face
well enough to test fit in a virtual
simulated context
so we had issues with um you know
being able to clearly specify what was
hurt and what was soft
being able to tell when things
intersected it just it wasn't feasible
to do a good job of this here
we also ended up prototyping using a
variety of materials and it was hard to
take this back into the modeling system
so here
you can see um there is a paper cup that
we've cut fingers into
um and wrapped some some elastic around
and that
has a plastic liner inside it and
together that ended up creating a really
good fit
you can see that we did take this back
into our designs here
this is a student sonya jindal who is
actually putting wire through this to
help and there's some rubber on the
inside to help make that fit to face
happen
um and that that fit to face is
particularly necessary to replace n95
masks which was obviously a huge
issue over the last few months um
tools really make a difference so here
we happen to have a group that was doing
simulation of fabric
and we were able to make much faster
progress on developing gowns
because of those simulations although
there were still a lot of factors that
were not
effectively captured so here for example
danielle
review is reaching out because the seam
construction under the arm which was
done with heat sealing actually with
soldering irons at first
was not necessarily strong enough to
handle that kind of reaching and that
was something we had to test because it
couldn't just come apart unexpectedly
um another thing that ended up being a
challenge for our design process
was shifting technologies as we went
from
initial solutions to scalable solutions
it was really key that we were able to
repeatedly produce
the same thing over and over again have
quality assurance processes that were
trustworthy
and it turns out the supply chain for
what materials we could get
was also really key in deciding what
could be scaled and the supply chains
were a little bit unpredictable with
cobit and so we had to design
to them to some degree we considered
3d printing of course but we also looked
at molds and vacuum forming
and of course you can't think of these
in in a vacuum
so to speak right so this vacuum formed
design it right
is good as far as it goes but the time
it takes to cut it out and then assemble
other pieces to it could potentially
impact its viability
um another interesting thing about
vacuforming was that va clinics all over
the country have vacuum forming machines
so while it's not the first thing you
would necessarily think of for scaled
production
it turns out that we could do hyper
local production with vacuum forming in
a way that we couldn't with almost any
other technology
and at high speed so that was a
technology we investigated
significantly because of that feature of
va clinics
um but in any case each of these has
implications for model design so with
vacuum forming there are
directions that you can curve in in
other directions that you really
shouldn't
if you want something to to be
successfully vacuum formed and there
you know were issues with whether we
could make square versus round holes and
a whole variety of other things that
were
affected by the choice of that
technology
um a final challenge for our design
process was how to test
test things in the field really i would
say fit was just part of that
so um going back to the fit thing though
you know it took a long time to print
these masks
we tried things like printing partial
masks but it turns out that it's just
too unrealistic because people position
it in ways that
that would are not capturing potential
problems say with the nose in this case
with kelly
and although measurement is a not a
popular problem to study because it
seems as though we have great tools for
reconstructing 3d shape
it is a really huge issue in the field
we couldn't set things up
in a reliable way at the speed we needed
to in the hospitals we were testing in
to capture
measurements and so we ended up playing
around with various kinds of things
that had known size and were easy to
capture with a simple photo
and then measure on top of in order to
try to get a sense of face size
and we needed to know face size because
there's a lot of different face sizes we
had a lot of different mask designs and
we needed to get a sense of how those
mapped onto each other because
eventually
for n95 testing for example we need to
show that a certain percentage of
different face shapes are covered well
by the masks that we produce
um i also want to point out that you
know here's a bunch of different
pictures of me wearing a bunch of
different masks most of these don't fit
me
but it's not immediately obvious from
the picture that that is so
you know this one it left with a
different person wearing it that has
the obvious bump over the nose with lots
of room for air to flow
yes you can see that that doesn't fit
but it's not necessarily clear in these
other spaces
um so we did a lot of work on trying to
collect
um qualitative reliable qualitative
feedback about fit to face
and thinking about you know we have to
really talk to stakeholders to
understand
what really mattered here um nose
comfort turned out to be a big thing but
there's also have
things that have to do with how many
hours you wear them that we weren't
going to get in our tests because people
were only willing to put a short amount
of time into them
and i should also mention that this is
probably the most challenging user
testing i've ever done
we spent a good three to four hours over
multiple sessions practicing our user
study
in a lab because we needed to make sure
that it was covered safe and here we
have masks going on people's faces
right and we need to do it from a
distance we need to make sure
everything's clean between every
participant we could not produce enough
masks to throw them away after every
test
and we just had to go through a huge
amount of
testing it was also really hard to
recruit people and the students who
stepped up to go into the hospital
system and do the tests
you know didn't know what risks they
were taking at that time in the whole
process so
was it was a big deal to do these tests
um okay the next challenge i want to
mention is design approval
so the main path for getting these
approved is through the nih 3d print
exchange
and this could get you what's called
clinical approval
so they had a rapid process in place
they intentionally brought down the
barriers as much as possible
and we had an inn with beth who had been
interviewed in studies of ours in the
past is from seattle and was
closely tied to our innovation team and
wanted to see our things make it through
the system
overall however of everything that was
submitted to nih
500 over 500 items were submitted and
517 were never checked or there's no
info about them
um only 34 were reviewed for clinical
use and
and approved for clinical use 28 were
optimized
for community use meaning that you could
give them to like restaurant workers or
grocery store workers but not
to a hospital and 32 actually got a
warning as
explicitly tagged as potentially unsafe
among our designs two were were actually
reviewed and approved for clinical use
and as i mentioned
others never made it through the process
even um
and there were several challenges here
um
one big one was that they were just
gummed up with
many many many variants on designs
nobody knew what variants
were were big enough to lead to a need
for clinical re-evaluation
and so even just looking at face shields
there's a number of designs that
ended up being uploaded to the 3d print
exchange and having to be evaluated
because we don't have a good way
to automatically assess whether a change
is consequential or not
or how big a change it is um
okay the other approval process that you
have to go through is niosh
for the kind of ppe we were creating and
in particular
we can't deploy our n95 masks because
they have to go through niosh approval
and niosh never got around to making a
fast-tracked version of this
um in order to get the n95 masks
approved we need to do a fit test
with at least 25 participants with face
sizes
falling into these different buckets um
and 50 percent much pet must pass so
that's not the barrier
we can do that what's harder is we need
to use a testing rig
and we need a company and a for-profit
company to get involved
there is no way for an academic unit or
a team like ours to even
enter the process without a company so
this is still in progress
um okay challenge number four what am i
doing on
i don't time where my clock is i'm just
gonna trust that we're okay
um challenge number four is design
generality
um and so what we need to do for design
is um make sure that things can
be reused and this came up most often in
the in the mask fit to face
domain because there's so many different
uses for that once you have it
so it wasn't long before we switched
from this design at top left which
really can only be used in one way with
one kind of n95 filter
to something that was modular which had
the advantage that we could for example
put different kinds of filters on it
or even as i mentioned earlier do
something like a non-rebreather
that was completely different from the
original goal for that design
of course the tools that we had for
developing this didn't specifically
support this kind of modularity um
an example of the non-rebreather by the
way adaptation you can see that in
addition to changing what we put in the
hole in the center of that design we
also added
flaps here because it's okay to breathe
out the non-rebreather's importance has
to do with what's coming in
um another issue with modularity
again goes back to measurement because
um for example if we were attaching
these tubes for some reason to this mask
the size of the the diameter of those
tubes is different and at least there
we're going with round to round but
often it might be a square peg you have
to
fit into your round hole right and so
simply having tools that would make it
easy to generate these kinds of
connectors on the fly
would allow a approval say for a mask
that fits a face
to go to be done once and then have that
connected to many different devices
that's not something that's easily
supported by tools yet
the last thing i want to mention as a
challenge is longitudinal viability this
is not something that we studied in the
cobot case but what i'm showing here is
actually the cello recital
of a boy who has a limb difference
um he's wearing this device that you see
on the left that's marked 2015.
he's actually wearing the exact same
device um
we updated it um within about three or
four months with a slightly different
connector for the bow holder
but what you're seeing in this 2020
image is actually what his mom had to do
when he outgrew the original gauntlet
she just molded this out of some kind of
clay and put it back together
we're trying to work with her to get her
to measure his arms so that we can
produce a new gauntlet for her
but the idea that um i mean first of all
this is a success right it was used for
five years straight by this boy but
secondly again the process itself
doesn't naturally support
these kinds of updates over time and
particularly when you think about the
relationship that
develops between makers and recipients
and groups like enable there's not
necessarily support for this kind of
back and forth over time
okay and i guess i'll just add to that
that we had stories from people where
the the turnover in the maker
volunteers was just too high to support
that so it's not that those
relationships couldn't be created but
there's a lot of barriers in terms of
how to make that happen
so here's a summary of the five
challenges i mentioned quality control
design process
design approval design generality and
longitudinal viability
what can we do to address these of
course being a technologist that's
where i want to go next or first even
and i do believe that there are places
that we could do better
so for example we could think about
increasing support for prototyping in
the design process and i'll talk a
little bit
about some of the work we've done there
we could think about what a medical
grade cad tool would look like
how might you design a cad tool that's
meant to operate in clinical settings
um we could think about case management
systems enable has deployed one and is
starting to see some progress because of
that right so how do these kinds of
things fit in
i think there's a huge number of open
problems here and i'm not going to have
time nor do i have the results in this
talk to tell you what the answer is to
all of these
but if we're going if we're serious
about 3d printing and other fabrication
technologies
leaving the lab and the hobbyist space
we're going to have to think about these
kinds of things in order to make it to
the next level
so i'm just going to focus on this
actually the top two here today
and i want to talk a little bit more
about prototyping so i showed this image
of a paper cup
but this isn't the first time we've seen
low end technologies be valuable in
prototyping so for the cello bow holder
that i showed you one of our very first
iterations actually involved
lego and the reason is that actually it
comes down to measurement which i'll
talk about a little bit more in a second
it's hard to know how long the gauntlet
and the bow holder needed to be
in order to support cello playing
effectively for this young man
and it turns out that the length of your
arm affects how you
lean and reach it can affect back health
and it can affect the quality of your
sound if you don't get it right but
there isn't something there that you can
measure
so the ability to explore and to explore
rapidly and iteratively
faster than you can 3d print is really
essential and that's what we were
explaining
exploring in this particular thing um
and here we just you know obviously
we're just iterating because we didn't
know how to solve the problem and we
needed to try different design ideas
um moving on to measurement
um it turns out that measurement is
really
hard for everyday people so um june kim
um helped lead a study on mechanical
turk a few years ago where we asked
people to measure
known items at least two ways just
randomly
whoever signed up in mechanical turk and
people
were really bad at it it was they were
bad even if we hadn't asked them to do
it twice with two different devices
um and these are just some examples of
things that were hard so sometimes it
was the tool being used and that's what
you see here with this
sewing ruler that is flexible it has a
bump in it right so that's going to
affect accuracy
potentially and badly enough that your
iphone would fall out of its case if you
designed it using this measurement
um another issue is um shown in the the
second two photos is that it's not
always clear what to measure so here
we have a phone with a curved edge
while it is clear what to measure here
you need to use some degree of skill to
be able to figure out how to line up
something that's not against the ruler
and get the
correct measurement in this other case
we're measuring the diameter of the
bottom of this bulb
but because it is not a straight edge
it's not clear if you want the inner or
the outer diameter of these threads
right um and so there's a bunch of
knowledge
that we might assume but not not see in
people who need to do measuring that's
missing here we also measured the angle
of laptop screens like what is the
maximum
angle your laptop can go back to and
people's knowledge of how to use a
protractor or otherwise how to measure
angle was just
just non-existent right i mean it just
wasn't
there so there's a lot of issues with
measuring
and it comes up again and again and
every time i i talk about it as a
research problem
as i said i get pushback from people who
say well this is not a hard problem and
maybe it's like the star trek
doors it's that kind of thing that is
really hard but looks easy
and therefore hard to to focus on in
research but
it is definitely not solved um and it is
critical to getting things out there i
think into the world
another thing that we'd like to see um
made more feasible
is the use of multiple materials any of
the covert work that we did
that required softness was um a post-hoc
assembly process
right and masks comfort over many hours
on your face
really would benefit from softness
actually it was a running joke in our
group because
the best fit to face was almost
inevitably
when um when uh jeff lipton who led the
face mask work
would put a a piece of um plastic he
just took like
two millimeter plastic and cut out you
know a breathing hole and then just
used it as a skirt on various things
and we had this running joke that he
must have stocks and plastic because he
brought it up so many times and then the
gowns came along and we actually had a
use for it that the medical
professionals would accept
um but really it made a huge difference
in how comfortable and how
closely things fit face when we put that
there the ability to take
cloth or other soft materials and mix
them in with hard materials is critical
i believe for
for non-hobby deployable fabricated
technologies and i don't think it's
solved yet so although i'm showing some
examples here of work that we've done
to with knitting machines and cloth and
3d printing there's a lot left to do
there
the next thing i want to talk about is
medical grade cad and what that might
look like
um so
um the kinds of things that we need to
be able to do
in cad in order to keep track of
things like testing and clinical
validity have to do with
parameterization modularity requirement
specification and supporting all of that
in ways that are familiar to
people who are not necessarily
experts at doing this kind of work and
so
um and i'm noticing it's 145 so i'm
going to try to go quickly through this
piece so there's time for questions as
well
um we have been doing a lot of work
looking at
what kinds of designs people are making
now
that are out in the real world and we
focus on things on thingiverse
that have at least some real world
object involved in them
because that's starting to get us out of
the hobby space just a little bit
and we see that things like bounding
boxes or
molding to shape or sweat paths are
examples of things that are done a lot
in many different contexts
so in the parts project that megan led
what we did was we developed a library
of reusable
parts so you could select something from
the library
such as an adjustable cup holder and
then
it was pre-configured with the
parameters that you might need
and most importantly it was also
pre-configured with a set of modular
things that represent not only the part
but also how it interacts with the world
so these see-through models represent a
pipe um
and a cup in the context of a workshop
where we asked people to make cup
holders that could clamp onto their
bicycle using a pipe clamp
another thing that you can see here is
that we had taking
learnings from our measurement work we
realized that if people are bad at
measurement
we might want to address this in the
model in particular if we make models
that accommodate measurement error
then it's not as critical that
measurements are perfect and so in this
case
the idea would be to print a ring of
flexible material as well as a ring of
hard material and
join them together in order to
accommodate measurement error in the
size of a cup
for example
when two parts are put together if you
have information about how they're
expected to be used you can start to
do validation and so here you can see on
the left
the pipe that the pipe clamp is holding
is intersecting the cup
um although neither of those are part of
the actual model it's critical to know
that they intersect because it's not
going to work on your bike to put your
cup in if it hits your handlebar
and these these expectations are things
that can be specified in the tool and
attached to these models that can then
be imported and used
this was done in fusion 360. so here's
an example of a
usable version of this cup holder it's
not pretty but it's demonstrating
what's doable in terms of using these
kinds of assertions and other aspects of
parts
and when we ran a workshop with people
who were either using fusion 360 or
parts
we saw that their ability to get all
that all the way to a functional print
was much higher so the purple bars are
are
our tool parts and the yellow bars are
the parts of the process
that people were able to successfully
achieve using fusion 360.
now these were beginners with both tools
and many people have told me in
criticisms of this work
that such facilities do exist in cad
tools today
but what we were trying to do was not
necessarily invent something that didn't
exist
but lower the bar to using it right i
think of this work as a little bit like
end user programming for cad
what can we do to bring software
engineering principles
into cad in a way that is supportive of
people who are not as expert that's what
we're trying to accomplish
um another thing we might want to be
able to let people do is
is specify requirements so these um
these models have some requirements
built into them in the
in a cad sense like the possibility for
a pipe to go through a certain amount of
space
but there's a lot of things you might
care about in requirements and i'm going
to actually shift over into the knitting
space for a minute because that's where
we're about to present this work at west
and that's the space that i have
an example of this in um so the idea
that that we're exploring here
is whether we can develop a pipeline for
optimization
that can let people choose
tactics for improving a design
and objectives which are essentially
requirements for what that design should
do
and have that work in a general
optimization pipeline
and we did that in the context of
knitting um
and what we do is we let people select
among a library of objectives we haven't
yet worked out
how somebody might using end user
programming tools
specify those objectives but those
objectives tell us
things like this lampshade should be
tighter
around the top and the bottom and it
should be see-through in the middle and
things like that
um and then tactics tactics are
different kinds of knit stitches in this
case
that you could substitute for what's
called plain net or stockinette
that would help achieve these goals and
then we use
an optimization based solution that
can take a map that connects objectives
and tactics so
you need to tell the system what tactics
are likely to help you get closer to the
objective in other words
and the rest is automated um and here's
a picture of sort of
the pattern also being broken up into
pieces
so for this lampshade what we eventually
knit was a tube
that had a tighter structure at the top
and bottom and stripes
along the sides and so we actually
specified different objectives and
tactics for each of these four different
kinds of pieces
in the pattern and in the and the result
matched our goal um
so that's all i'm going to say about
those two things um
i just want to highlight again that
there's a lot of open challenges here
and i hope that um lots of people start
working on them because i think there's
a lot to do
to get to the next level of fabrication
work
sorry james i didn't say much about
create but i covered lots of other
ground today
happy to take questions now thanks for
the great talk
jen i wanted to ask about this like one
sentence you mentioned really early on
about
the differences in community acceptance
of like make for kovid
that make for covet achieved versus like
the uw kovid like task force and i was
wondering if you could just talk a
little bit more about that and like why
you saw the differences and like what
caused those differences
yeah um i don't think i have a great
answer to that um
i will say that the uw task force was
conceived and run by the uw hospital
system the medical school and they had a
really clear goal
at the beginning which had to do with
trying to make sure that
they did not run out of ppe right i mean
that was the first goal and
and you know it's one of the bigger
hospitals in the area but it was also
that was where it was safe to send
things if they had been approved by our
group
um and we had the in there and we knew
what we were doing
um and we did run into some issues later
when we wanted to distribute more
broadly also
with just concerns about liability and
other things
i think that the center of mass of make
for covid although there were academics
involved
was outside of the university and
medical system
and so i think they had the freedom to
do things differently
the other thing that i think is really
critical was that for better
for worse they just had buy-in of the
maker community in a way that we did not
achieve and
i think we were a little bit late
reaching out perhaps
um but there were there ended up being
parallel efforts in seattle
and um and so they just went in
different directions
what what the makers in seattle were
doing and what we were doing
and but when we were ready to try to
reconnect
it it was um not i don't think either
group would have
willingly handed the other the reigns
and
and it wasn't clear how to collaborate
without doing that
so i think good people trying to do good
things in both places but just really
really different outcomes
good question yeah uh great talk jen
thanks so much for sharing all the
things that you've been doing and and
it's exciting to see um kind of
following up a little bit on the
question i think that um the really
interesting one of the really
interesting things you talked about was
you know the the socio-technical
challenges of the
community aspect as well as like
collaboration i'm wondering if you can
talk more about
you know approaches that you've seen in
terms of uh yeah
i guess different approaches to
collaborative support
for people working on innovation
together there's been a lot of work in
that space in the past
in both in terms of like um yeah you
know more from the
emmy uh you know design and innovation
side of things
but then i wonder now there's also this
thread of community support tools
emerging
um in cscw and do you feel like there
are yeah
things that you think might help to sort
of provide this community support or
help manage that because it seems like
that's
a real challenge that you observed is
the tension between clinicians and the
people that want to help and how do you
get everyone on the same page yeah well
i mean there's a lot of different
questions i think hidden in what you
just raised
i'll start with just what we actually
used right so we use google docs
and we use slack more than anything else
and zoom
right um so those were really valuable
um
one of the things that was surprising to
me was that we
we are still seeing barriers of people's
level of comfort with technology being
an issue in some of the collaboration
we're doing
so not everyone was
equally comfortable with those tools and
were even using them and then on top of
that when we started to go out into the
field like to do tests in the hospital
getting google forms working properly
counting on network
connectivity in the hospitals being able
to get people to upload
photos they took off their phones those
all ended up being challenges
so for all of the like progress that
we've made with tools
some fairly old challenges are still
very much present
in our efforts to work together um
we also needed to deal with differences
in hardware so shipping files around
from site to site was okay
but not necessarily sufficient for
making sure that we had things
fully replicated um and so
so those are some of the things that
were challenges and the hardware piece
of course being new in the 3d printing
domain perhaps right or bringing back
old things that haven't been an issue
for a while um
in terms of how well tools build
trust i'm not sure it's tools i think
it's
time and face-to-face communication that
is still
at the core of getting communities
connected and building their trust and
ability to connect with
each other um although there were also
security issues so
like make for covid for example had a
just a sign-in wall between you and
their documentation because they just
didn't want anyone coming up and looking
at it for example right
and we had some of those kinds of things
also
in the seattle group so yeah i guess i'm
i don't feel like i'm really answering
your question because i don't think i
know the answer
but i do think that being like realistic
about the fact that there's still
age-old challenges age-old is unfair
computers haven't been around that long
but you know
that some of those things are still
there is important to acknowledge
did that help at all yeah thanks
good and we have a question from a
student who's in the seminar and
submitted a question
um is wondering they say you know
you had to put in a lot of effort trying
to redesign
um what are sold in as really well
established products like mass
and face shield and they were wondering
whether it would be possible or how it
would be possible to
instead go work with industry to
basically devote your resources instead
of
through this trial and error process to
the actual sort of
uh creation of more of these things
instead of starting from scratch
so that's a really good question um so
adriana schultz for example who's the
the graphics professor who was doing
leading the gown design effort
she ended up talking to rei at one point
and other companies to the about
manufacturing
but the issue was that the um the
sourcing for these things wasn't working
right so this maybe was a really unique
thing
to that moment in time but there just
wasn't there weren't enough
people who were able to produce the
material to make n95 masks
the people who normally produce gowns
were not being able to
we're not successfully producing them
and delivering them at the scale that
was needed
and so the focus became on what we could
do locally
um and that did include talking to
companies but if a company that didn't
normally produce hospital gowns was
suddenly re-revising what their faculty
was producing they needed
models and guides and so that was where
what we were doing for example with the
gown work
with the mask and 95 work we were trying
to figure out ways of reducing the
amount of filter material that was
needed so that you could cut up
a mask if you had it and put it into
that square holder that you saw for
example
or you could take that round holder had
like a
a piece of material that's normally used
in i think furnace systems or something
right that was m95
quality so could you take advantage of
other manufacturing pathways
and bring that into something that fit
to face
so that was what was driving that work
was this need to do sort of hyper local
production in the absence of a supply
chain that was functioning properly
and one other question that we got is
wondering what kinds of limitations you
saw on digital platforms for sharing or
collaborating on designs like
thingiverse nih 3d printed so on
in the context of designing and sharing
medical devices specifically
yeah um so i mean the nih platform was
working
um and it it does let you upload some
quality
assurance related kinds of stuff like
guides for how to use it properly and so
on
um it wasn't a collaboration platform
and in fact the
more variants of things that were
submitted again the more it kind of
gummed up the whole approval process as
far as i could tell
um it was explicitly a choice
um in our group not to put the stuff on
places like thingiverse but a lot of
stuff did show up on thingiverse and a
lot of design variants
came out of that um so i do think that
sharing ideas is possible on thingiverse
in our interviews with makers in the
past
um who worked in the medical system
there was a lot of concern about
sharing models for things that might put
them in a situation where they had
liability
so it was okay to share within their
institution
similar to sort of what we had in the
seattle domain but not necessarily
outside the institution what was more
people were more interested in sharing
was learning
um outside the institution and i think
that
if we had better tools for being able to
describe what was
a use of something that stayed within
the clinically valid
um range for parameters of that thing
it might be more feasible to share
things more widely
um so megan talks a lot to me about
clinical cad and what that might look
like
and whether we could do that support
that kind of sharing but at least for
things that have health and safety risks
it's a very
fine line what can be shared and what
can't i think broadly speaking
well we have another one i'll ask one
final one
um
does i guess in your experience was
there a tension between makers and
clinicians in the development of this
kind of technology
or is it any better or worse than it
would be in other situations
um within our group in seattle i don't
think there was tension
um there was eagerness to work together
it was
actually from me personally i don't
think i've ever been
part of such a large group of faculty
who are mostly doing their own work
students usually you do the work for us
right
it was it was a really interesting
experience
and um there was a ton of back and forth
work of like how do we do this the level
of support for getting things into the
hospital to do the testing was super
high
people were really eager to bring ideas
to the team we met weekly as a
group to discuss what new needs
were developing that we might be able to
address and you know
some things ended up being failures so i
didn't really talk about it but there
was something that came out of china i
think that was like a
um a box that you could put over
somebody's face
and then stick your hands underneath the
box so your face was above it
like plexiglas for protection and like
intubate for example and it turned out
eventually that kobud was so airborne
that this was not actually a safe
solution for anything
and but we got quite far with um taking
the initial design which was already
very good and
testing it and modifying it and then we
just dropped it when it wasn't safe
anymore
nobody was upset about that because the
makers trusted the clinicians about
safety as much as the clinicians trusted
the makers about how do we do this right
um and it was really you know everyone
stepping up i mean at one point we had a
material science
uh question and a faculty member that i
knew in material science spent
you know much of his evening and late
into the night doing the research
necessary to help answer that question
even though he wasn't even part of the
team
and i think that was all he did for most
of the time that we were doing this work
but it was crucial when it happened
right and so it was also just this
moment in time when everyone was like
let's work together let's make things
happen it was pretty cool to be part of